welcome to this video playing just
kitten yeah we have some kind of history
but I cannot really remember I don't
have a good score okay let's play the
tirage mainline him he's very quick i
knows that line okay check yeah this is
not the most critical line against 94
but when I looked at this while ago I
felt that it's still reasonably
uncomfortable for four black players to
face so um to f6 Bishop g4 might be on
so I'm going to go here be four Bishop
g4 looked a bit annoying in this fairly
symmetrical position I have the slightly
better Bishop and a bit more development
it's not great by any means but ok night
age 41 so it's going back to the seventh
and are probably on hmm
maybe okay so he I cannot take twice
that because of Bishop g5 yeah okay if I
take the bishop will be very well placed
on d5 so that isn't a particularly great
prospect yeah it's just equal
chan yeah oh I'm still playing on a
little bit even though really nothing is
going on you can even argue that Lex
king is a little bit quicker but it
shouldn't really be important so maybe
just back not question yeah I'm probably
just back
I would like to play 95 it's not
possible so i'm going to remove the
bishop
hmm ok I instead a draw I'm not going to
claim anything here but each six looked
a bit more normal
I would not put anything on light
squares there but ok it really doesn't
matter and it is still it wrong
still surprised that he that he did this
here in the first place again something
on a light square is playing be five at
the way it would be trying to yeah
trying to make fun of white a little bit
like i can play some rubbish roofs and
still draw which is probably true but be
five I mean it's not going to do that
he has put even more on light squares
it's again it's probably not not that
important angling for Bishop to e8
Bishop f7 and then h4 that's actually
slightly annoying him okay this should
be a to Bishop age three Bishop g6
Bishop g4 and then temple move hmm or h4
immediately how is he playing against
that entering with the king or not I can
our King e6 check and then I've entered
with a king so it can go image for here
check
so King mm Bishop d5 is also possible
and then start with this smooth start
with this one
Jim its control is still draw me Nia's
may I should have taken that porn down
against it's possibly this is just too
close to win time warning
King opponent game is always losing
so still a bit tricky cakes conceived
for King d6 can be five Kings seven King
a six king c6 not winning some good
defense good defense I had to try that
down to trapping my bishop and I don't
think so and so let's see probably to g6
and tried for some check super songs him
Chad now it's difficult for him zoosk
one to give up poor now one of those and
maybe Bishop g6 was better I had the
wrong the wrong porn yeah didn't think
about this one Jeff like forfeits on
time i forfeit it on time what he's on 0
here and i was i was just ahead on the
clock here why did I forbid on time what
Jay
yeah great great probably this is the
history that i have against him i had to
add a bad feeling that yeah i mean this
is kind of that's really an actually
very embarrassing game public because
it's just a dead end game chanta he
manages to manages to lose that on the
board um yeah when here you just go age
six and it's dead just dad dad dad
nothing happens okay it's still it wrong
but he just voluntarily put stuff on
light squares which is not necessary at
all and yeah check anyway can only i
marry so maybe this here already this is
already a problem you cannot cover both
that would have one already yeah and
ultimately already got to winning
position yes turn that off of tempe
words okay i were to 12 seconds King a
success much better that really puts
them into into the suits one check damn
plus a million okay but it had to we had
to be quick and of course guaranteed did
all those little tricks with bishop g6
and so on to ultimately somehow win on
time with both clocks being on 000
anyway thanks for watching